can you do an impression of any
character in this film other than your
own character okay I'm Kenny thank you
looking at i/o now you have to do you
like the way you throw chicken feed
wasn't I great by the way I suddenly
struck me seeing Thursday's I just want
to put it
I did one is brilliant there denieth
doing again you've thrown chickens in a
blender like the best ability Irish
chicken scene throw rebels there you go
it's my bail can you do an impression of
any character in the film other than
your own character we're going there oh
my god
are you--is antlers and all of my
decorating I love it I guess I could be
like mm-hmm it could be like to be mmm I
love it I love it Dan had so much motion
capture for his face if we were to
motion capture you and your trailer
filming this film what expression would
we most often see he's like yeah I was
just going to be like trying to hold up
the way we were to motion capture your
face behind the scenes directing what
expression will be most often see I have
to say real delight yeah I remember the
first time that I saw like a good
version of the the beasts face for the
for the scene where he sings evermore
this new song and I was it really got me
crying what expression would be most
often see
the eyebrows that's such a weird funny
question I was regularly overheating in
the 40-pound lycra muscle suit that I
was wearing that kind of overheated hot
bothered face whatever whatever that
looked like it's very red it was my face
in my trailer
oh my god is coming alright my favorite
quote in the entire film is when Gaston
says that he likes Belle - she hasn't
made a fool of herself in order to get
his face had you ever made a fool of
yourself in order to gain somebody's
favor I made a fool of myself when I
first met my then girlfriend who became
my fiancee became my wife I I tried to
put in a kiss into a scene that was
completely inappropriate for the two of
us to kiss and she was like no that
won't work in the contract yeah yeah
good job work clothes isn't all you do
when you fall in love yes I was just
about to say that I think yeah every
time I've been in love I've made a total
fool of myself I think it's Paul it's
like popsicles how do you turn it into
your favorite then make you the other
credible yes you hope that they think
it's cute
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]